nach der klassischen urknalltheorie der
big bang theory begann unser universum
jahr vor etwa 13,8 zwei milliarden
jahren mit dem urknall
gleichzeitig entstanden demnach auch
raum und zeit wenn wir davon ausgehen
hat sich die frage was war von dem
urknall eigentlich erledigt aber
mittlerweile gibt es weitere
überlegungen dazu die sich auf die
quantentheorie stützen und danach gibt
es tatsächlich ein davor
doch wie genau soll das aus ist das
universum vielleicht aus dem nichts
entstanden war es teil eines
multiversums oder ist es noch oder
markiert unser urknall
lediglich das ende eines vorherigen
bezüglich universums die antworten jetzt
wirklich zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
macht wieder vielen dank für diesen
spannenden themen vorschlag aus der web
community wie ihr mitglied dort werden
könnt ihr vater am ende des videos erste
theorie
das universum ist zyklisch vor ihm
existiert ein anderes universum
eine idee ist dass vor unserem universum
ein anderes universum existiert hatte
was sich immer weiter ausgedehnt hat bis
es dann in sich zusammengefallen ist
dann beginnt alles von vorn so war also
unser urknall der letzte moment eines
anderen universums und vor diesem hatte
wiederum ein anderes universum existiert
vor dem urknall hätte somit also einen
früheren urknall gegeben und vor diesem
einen noch früheren und so weiter doch
dann gibt es eine weitere berechtigte
frage die sich dem anschließt was war
denn vor dem ersten urknall
wenn man diesen gedanken mal weiter
springen kommt man ja auch zu einer viel
größeren frage die wir aber eigentlich
damit meinen wie ist alles entstanden
übrigens wem jetzt die antwort gott in
den sinn kommt muss dann aber auch
weiter fragen was war vor gott diese
theorie des zyklischen universum es wird
auch big points genannt und das heißt so
viel wie großer rückprall demnach hat
auch eine kollision ein vorher und
nachher heißt aber auch dass wir von dem
gedanken uns verabschieden müssen dass
der urknall der anfang von allem sein
und darum dass alles zu belegen müsste
die stringtheorie weiter ausgeklügelt
werden zudem bräuchte es empirische
belege der plan dazu satelliten
teleskope könnten demnächst eventuell
nachweisen dass die schwache
mikrowellenstrahlung also das echo des
urknalls in einem zyklischen universum
andere eigenschaften hat als im
herkömmlichen big bang universum zweite
theorie unser universum ist teil eines
umfassenden multiversums dahinter steckt
die idee des sogenannten eckbüro tischen
universums demnach ist unser universum
noch lange nicht alles sondern nur ein
kleiner teil eines viel umfassenderen
multiversums darin existieren viele
einzelne universen die ab und an
miteinander kollidieren das wäre dann
quasi der moment des ur kratz und
tatsächlich besteht hierbei die
möglichkeit solch eine kollision
nachzuweisen und zwar durch eine
detaillierte untersuchung der kosmischen
hintergrundstrahlung sehr wahrscheinlich
es ist allerdings nicht dass wir
irgendwann solche hinweise finden werden
um jetzt konkret auf die frage zu handen
was jetzt genau vor dem urknall wäre
wäre die antwort dann ein multiversum in
dem prozess zum urknall geführt haben
doch letztendlich ist die frage damit
auch nicht final geklärt denn mit dieser
theorie schließt sich eine weitere frage
an wie ist dann dieses multiversum
entstanden gab es ein multi knall
umfasst ja was war dann nach vor die
idee des multiversums scheint wirklich
nicht überprüfbar zu sein
deswegen gibt es auch im großen
widerstand gegen die theorie dritte
theorie und die ist wirklich ja ich
würde mal sagen ein bisschen spooky das
universum ist aus dem nichts entstanden
die moderne physik ist mittlerweile der
ansicht dass dinge tatsächlich aus dem
nirgendwo entstehen können diese meinung
ist spektakulär und galt in der
wissenschafts community lange zeit als
undenkbar
das universum entstanden aus dem nichts
genau davon gehen mittlerweile einige
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus aber wie kann das sein ganz am
anfang standen demnach wohl winzige
energie geladene teilchen sogenannte
quanten und jetzt gibt es auch schon ans
eingemachte denn vielleicht ist ja dass
es laut der quantenmechanik eigentlich
gar keinen leeren raum geben kann
doch die forschungsteams die an die
entstehung des universums aus dem nichts
glauben beziehen sich auf die
quantengravitation danach ist die
quantenmechanik mit der der
quantengravitation vereint und somit
sind zufällige und sehr kurze energie
schwankung selbst in einem vakuum
möglich in der fachsprache auch
quantenfluktuationen teilchen und das
entsprechende anti teilchen entstehen
spontan und löschen sich kurze zeit
später gegenseitig wieder aus
doch eventuell kam es ja zu einer
gleichverteilung also einem überschuss
von materie antimaterie dann wird er
tatsächlich vermutet nur keiner weiß
warum es sie gab dann würde ein bisschen
mehr materie bestehen bleiben und könnte
so nach ansicht der forscherinnen
forscher für den ganzen galaxien und
sternen geführt haben wie wir sie heute
aus dem universum kennen
es ist schon eine klasse vorstellung
denn so eine kleine asymmetrie vor sehr
langer zeit hätte dann so viel materie
erzeugt wie das universum heute
beinhaltet doch diese theorie nachdem
das universum aus dem nichts entstanden
sein könnte wird heiß diskutiert doch
fest steht auch fanden fluktuationen ja
die sind messbar also experimentell
gesichert möglich scheint es also schon
dass das ganze als aus der lehre
entstand alles in allem kommen wir da
aber an die grenzen unserer erkenntnisse
und viele fragen zum beispiel der frage
nach gott und dem ursprung von allem und
vielleicht können wir diese erkenntnis
grenzen überwinden wenn es allerdings
neues dazu gibt dann erfahrt ihr es
natürlich hier bei klingt und wenn ihr
kein video dazu und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollte die youtube aber
ob sie funktioniert ja absolut na ja gar
nicht eigentlich dann endet mich bei
whatsapp nur dann verpasst er kein video
über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir noch
vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich um garantiert und zu brüsten
habe ich ein kleines geschenk für euch
einfach draufklicken und am besten auch
meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social
media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste
aus der social media welt wie aktuell
über die anzeige gegen nebel nie wegen
eines - total irre dafür hier kriegen
aber nicht die schwimmer flocke
vergessen
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken sensation dunkle materie
existiert wahrscheinlich nicht bis dann
bleibt dran